there's no greater piece of equipment
that's gonna translate into your game
more than a bet my whole life better
revolve around baseball
I probably started from the time I was
four years old I ended up playing at
Providence College and was drafted in
the first round by the Toronto Blue Jays
in 1996 I had a lifelong dream of
playing in the big leagues I was on
40-man roster for two years never really
getting that chance to get a major
league at-bat
so I started my own bad company I've
only been doing this for about two and a
half years full-time and we're still a
very small company we have a very good
share of the market at the major league
level for being such a new company my
business plan if you want to call it
that when I started this thing in my
garage was if I could get this to a
level where I can kind of convince major
league players to use our bats I feel it
would be easier to convince everyone
else in the country to use them as well
very first major leaguer to actually
order our bats was Gaby Sanchez he kind
of grabbed one of our bats as he was
walking by five minutes later cannot see
me and said I love it you know I want to
order it doesn't here's our first order
and it was literally just a half of a
piece of scrap paper just with the order
written on it we currently have 160
different major players who use our bats
this side is predominately all maple
this side is a lot of ash the process of
making a bat starts with the wood trying
to get the highest quality wood so our
storage room was completely sealed off
and humidity controlled once the wood is
selected it is cutting into its final
shape and it's put onto our manual laid
and sanded and steel burnished once the
bat is painted and once it is dry is now
ready to be engraved the model number
and name if players wish is now engraved
on the barrel and the bat is now
complete and ready for shipping this
business has definitely got me back into
baseball that was the whole premise of
this business kind of happy it did for
the first time my life since being a
player I feel like what I am you know I
feel like a bat maker
you